Ich habe Hunderten von Menschen,
denen es finanziell sehr schlecht geht,
Grundeinkommen ausgezahlt mit meinem
Verein über die letzten Jahre. Ich habe
mit der Lupe danach gesucht, nach der einen
Person, die Alkohol kauft und faul
wird und völlig
verlottert. Das Gegenteil ist passiert.
-Aber das erzählt doch auch keiner von uns.
-Herzlich willkommen! Wir spielen 13
FRAGEN, hier kommt Frage Nr. 1:
Brauchen wir ein bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen?
Ja oder nein? Weniger
Existenzangst, mehr Freiheit. Das ist die Idee hinter
dem bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen.
Egal ob du arm bist oder reich, der Staat zahlt
jedem von uns jeden Monat 1200 Euro
aufs Konto und zwar ohne Gegenleistung,
ohne Bürokratie. Stellt sich nur die Frage:
Wer soll das bezahlen? Und geht
dann überhaupt noch jemand
arbeiten? Was meint ihr? Wo würdet ihr euch
positionieren? Auf dem grünen Feld
oder auf dem gelben? Schreibt es mir gerne
in die Kommentare. So wo ihr steht,
wissen wir natürlich schon, das sehen wir ja
auch ganz gut. In Zukunft bitte
folgende Regel beachten: Wenn ihr glaubt,
die Gegenseite macht da einen guten
Punkt, ein gutes Argument, dann kommt gerne einen
Schritt vor, also einen Schritt auf die Gegenseite
zugelaufen. Wenn ihr aber
umgekehrt sagt Nee, das stimmt gar
nicht, da bin ich vehement dagegen, dann geht
ihr bitte einen Schritt zurück. Mein Ziel
ist es, ganz klar Kompromisse zu finden
und euch dazu zu bewegen, eben
auch ins Kompromissfeld zusammenzukommen.
Ob das bei dem Thema klappt? Schauen
wir mal. Hier kommt Frage 2 von 13 FRAGEN
und die geht an unseren
Bäckermeister Karsten. Was würde ein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen für deinen Betrieb,
ich glaube vierte Generation inzwischen,
bedeuten? Würdest du
selbst aufhören zu arbeiten?
Also ich persönlich würde gar
nicht aufhören zu arbeiten. Also nicht
nur das Backen ist mein Leben,
sondern auch das Betrieb führen mache ich total
gerne. Und von daher sehe ich keine
Notwendigkeit, auch nicht wenn ich 1200
Euro kriege dafür meinen Beruf an den Nagel
zu hängen, weil ich mich persönlich
-darin erfüllt sehe.
-Und welche Auswirkungen glaubst du, würde
das auf deinen
Betrieb, auf Personal etc. haben?
Na, es gäbe bestimmt schon einige
Leute, die sagen würden "Dafür stehe ich nachts
nicht auf!" oder kommen würden und sagen
würden "Chef, ich arbeite gerne bei dir
weiter, aber zu den und den Bedingungen!"
und das ist für mich halt die größte
Problematik, weil ich nicht genau
weiß, was dann auf mich zukommt bzw.
ob ich das nachher leisten kann.
Ich glaube, dass die Befürworter des
bedingungslosen Grundeinkommens
einfach viele Sachen nicht bedenken, die uns
kleine Leute oder uns kleine
Handwerker beschäftigen und dass wir in vielen
Bereichen vielleicht die Sache
nicht bis zu Ende durchdacht haben.
-Was verdient denn ein Bäcker-Azubi?
-Ein Bäcker-Abzubi? Im dritten Lehrjahr
-sind wir knapp bei 900 Euro pro Monat.
-900 Euro.
-Brutto.
-Brutto, ja.
Tonia, wenn jetzt jemand kommt und dem Bäcker-Azubi
sagt "Pass auf, du hast 1200
Euro und muss nicht arbeiten oder du
kriegst 900 Euro und kannst ne schöne
Ausbildung machen." Da hat er natürlich
Sorge, dass er dann keine Auszubildenden
mehr findet, was eh schon
schwierig ist. Was würdest du ihm antworten?
Also ich glaube, wenn der Azubi 16
ist, dann stimmt es vielleicht manchmal,
aber auch nicht immer. Ich glaube,
wenn der potentielle Azubi vielleicht 28
oder 34 ist und sich überlegt, sich im Beruf
nochmal neu zu orientieren und sich
sagt "Ich möchte doch gern ein Handwerk
machen, ich koche total gerne, ich backe
total gerne, ich will sehen, was ich gemacht
habe mit meinen Händen."
Dann gewinnt man vielleicht sogar
neue Lehrlinge, die man vorher gar nicht
auf dem Schirm hatte. Weil mit dem Grundeinkommen
zusammen können das nämlich
-dann erwachsene Menschen plötzlich doch.
-Das ist richtig. Die Azubis haben wir ja
schon. Aber das Problem ist
doch: Was machen wir mit der Generation,
die von der Schule kommt, bis sie -
wie du sagst - nachher 23, 24 sind?
Ich glaube aber, auch in der Generation
bei den jungen hast du auch nicht alle,
die irgendwie sagen "Ich will nichts
machen!" Also ich glaube, dass wir immer
ein paar haben, die sagen "Super, ich leg
mich jetzt erst mal auf die faule Haut",
du hast aber eine ganze Menge
andere auch die sagen "Nein, natürlich will
ich in meinem Leben mehr
haben als ein Grundeinkommen."
Ja, aber die Geldfrage ist natürlich
schon eine spannende Frage, wieviel Motivation
dahinter steht. Gerade wenn es an diesen Grenzbereich
geht, also um die 1200 Euro,
wenn das Ausbildungsgehalt so ähnlich
oder weniger sogar ist, da muss man sich
die Frage natürlich stellen.
Interessiert mich auch, was ihr davon haltet.
Was würdet ihr mit dem Geld machen?
Euch auf die faule Haut legen oder sagen:
Ich mache jetzt mal was ganz
anderes, mache jetzt ne Bäcker-Lehre z.B.
Vielleicht gründet ihr auch ein Business?
Schreibt es mir gerne in die Kommentare.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, was eure Meinung
dazu ist, wenn ihr auf einmal 1200 Euro
bedingungslos auf dem Konto
hättet. Bleiben wir doch mal ganz kurz
bei der Frage, was mit Betrieben
passiert, die gerade auch Beschäftigte haben,
die auf so einer ähnlichen
Gehaltsstufe wie z.B. diese 1200 Euro sind. Ole,
kannst du die Sorge
nachvollziehen, die manche Leute haben, die sagen,
genau solche Betriebe kriegen
dann ein Problem möglicherweise?
Das kann ich tatsächlich auf jeden
Fall nachvollziehen. Ich glaube, dass viele
Menschen in insbesondere gut
bezahlten oder hoch angesehenen Berufen,
dass sie ihre Arbeit nicht
niederlegen werden. Aber ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass Leute, die Berufe machen, die erstens
schlecht bezahlt sind und zweitens
schlecht angesehen sind, dass die sich
dann tatsächlich fragen: Warum soll
ich das eigentlich machen? Ich glaube,
dass oft ein Wunschdenken vorherrscht
und das harte ökonomische Fakten
außenvorgelassen werden. Und das halte
ich eigentlich für das größte Problem,
daran krankt diese Debatte meiner Meinung
-nach am meisten.
-Was genau meinst du damit? Also manche
-Jobs werden dann nicht mehr erledigt?
-z.B. bei Reinigungskräften könnte ich mir
das gut vorstellen. Das sind Menschen,
die werden ganz häufig schlecht behandelt,
haben eine extrem harte Arbeit zu leisten
und sie werden schlecht bezahlt.
Und da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen,
glaube ich, dass viele dieser Menschen völlig
-zurecht sagen: Nein, möchte ich nicht.
-Ihr seid beide gleich da vorne gegangen,
-warum?
-Das könnte ein Effekt von Grundeinkommen
sein. Leute sind nicht mehr erpressbar.
Sie haben zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte
die Chance, Nein zu sagen zu Arbeit,
die sie nicht für würdig erachten.
Und was würde passieren? Unternehmer
müssten mehr Geld bezahlen, sie müssten
die Arbeit selber machen, sie müssten
die Arbeit auf mehrere Schultern verlagern
oder die Arbeitsbedingungen
verbessern. "Mein Grundeinkommen" will nicht gross
palavern, sondern einfach machen.
Und deshalb sammeln wir Geld, das dann
an Menschen verschenkt wird als Grundeinkommen
für ein Jahr. Das haben
wir bereits über 700 mal gemacht
und damit sammeln wir zum ersten Mal reale
Praxiserfahrungen wie denn ein Grundeinkommen
wirklich ein Leben
-verändern.
-Aber jetzt stellen wir uns doch mal vor,
ich bin kein netter Arbeitgeber. Ja,
und sage mir: 1200 Euro - mehr gibt's nicht.
Und dann sagt die Putzkraft zum Beispiel,
weil wir da bei dem Thema waren, ich bleib
zuhause. Jetzt sagt der Arbeitgeber
aber: Ich hol mir die Leute von draußen rein,
die für 1200 Euro
arbeiten. Die kriegen das dann auch?
Das ist eine Frage, welches Modell
man nimmt. Fast alle Grundeinkommens-Modelle
außer die von ganz rechts außen, die sagen,
dass den Menschen Grundeinkommen
ausgezahlt werden soll, die auch in Deutschland
gemeldet sind, wenn sie hier
z.B. arbeiten. Also ja, diese Menschen
müssten es auch kriegen.
Aber das müsste doch ganz anders
laufen. Also ich glaube das Modell, so
wie es jetzt klingt ist ja: Jeder
kriegt 1200 Euro. Und dann sagt Michael:
Und jeder der arbeitet, kriegt sofort
noch mehr. Ich bin gegen das bedingungslose
Grundeinkommen, weil ich glaube, dass man
das überhaupt gar nicht finanzieren kann
und dass die Leute, die ein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen wollen,
an einem Traumschloss bauen. Dann
würdest doch du als "böser Arbeitgeber" sagen:
Super, ich brauche jetzt jemanden, der hier
reinigt, dem hätte ich normalerweise,
sagen wir mal 1400 brutto gezahlt.
Jetzt kriegt er aber ja schon 1200 netto
als Grundeinkommen. Das nehme ich als Subvention
meines Betriebes, denn
ich mache das jetzt so: Die Putzfrau,
die kriegt jetzt nur noch 600 brutto. Macht ja
nichts, weil sie hat ja noch das Grundeinkommen
und hat mehr als vorher.
Mark, was sagst du zu dem Argument,
dass möglicherweise Arbeitgeber das Ganze
einfach missbrauchen und den Leuten
Dumpinglöhne zahlen?
Um jetzt wirklich zu verhindern, dass ein Arbeitgeber
plötzlich sagt: Ich setz dich
jetzt unter Druck, ich zahle jetzt
plötzlich nur noch drei Euro die Stunde,
dann haben wir die Möglichkeit,
mit politischem Willen zu sagen: Ne,
das akzeptieren wir grundsätzlich
nicht. Es gibt ja heute schon Mindestlohn
und das wird sich ja auch mit einem
bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen nicht
ändern müssen. Ich glaube, wir brauchen
viel mehr Modellversuche
zum Grundeinkommen, die staatlich
finanziert sind und die vor allem
auch von den Menschen ausgehen, weil ich glaube,
dass wir Menschen auf diesem Weg
deutlich freier,
solidarischer und produktiver wären.
Missbrauch vermeiden durch Mindestlohn
ist doch auch ein Argument, Ulrike, oder?
Genau, dann stelle ich mich
mal hier vorne hin. Das ist richtig.
-Da komme ich gleich mit.
-Also ich bin absolut für Mindestlöhne. Nur
mein Punkt wäre eben, dass man,
wenn man jetzt sozusagen das Los
der Niedrigverdiener verbessern
will, man nicht diesen weiten Umweg
um das bedingungslose Grundeinkommen
gehen sollte, das aus meiner Sicht nie kommt,
sondern dass man stattdessen sofort
als Reformfraktion sagen sollte: Wir wollen
einen höheren Mindestlohn, also
beispielsweise Mindestlohn von 15 Euro.
Ole, du sagst ja, Grundeinkommen
ist auch deswegen schon mal grundsätzlich
eine falsche Idee, weil es einfach
ungerecht ist. Wie meinst du das?
Ich würde sagen, dass nicht jeder den gleichen
Bedarf hat. Also für mich können
1200 Euro jetzt prima ausreichen.
Beispielsweise hab ich aber jahrelang
Wochenends einen Jungen mit geistiger
Behinderung betreut, der braucht mehr Geld
bzw. dessen Mutter braucht mehr Geld,
weil er insbesondere eine sehr intensive
Betreuung braucht. Ansonsten ist das für die gar
nicht zu stemmen. Was ich mich
dann frage ist: Ein Grundeinkommen, das diesen Namen
verdient, müsste für ihn also
höher sein, unterschiedlich hoch. Und dann
wäre es ja aber nicht mehr bedingungslos,
sondern sein Grundeinkommen, das höher
wäre als meines, wäre an die Bedingungen
geknüpft: Er hat eine Behinderung,
deshalb hat er Recht auf mehr Geld. Gibt es dann
überhaupt sowas wie ein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen für alle? Also diese 1200
Euro für alle muss ich ganz klar
sagen, die überzeugen mich gar nicht.
Könnt ihr das nachvollziehen, dass Ole
sagt: Naja, das funktioniert aber so
nicht. Und das ist irgendwie an sich
ungerecht, wenn alle das gleiche kriegen.
Ich kann den Gedanken nachvollziehen
und ich kann das Beispiel nachvollziehen,
was du gebracht hast, dass ihr gesagt:
Was passiert mit Menschen, die besondere
Bedarfe haben? Bei denen ist
das dann nicht abgedeckt. Aber da will
ich auch nochmal sagen:
Bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen bedeutet ja nicht,
dass ich sage, das Sozialsystem wird
abgeschafft. Und ganz grundsätzlich glaube
ich Grundeinkommen, wenn wir es uns
als Menschenrecht vorstellen, das fände
ich spannend, dass man sagt: Du bist
auf der Welt und allein dafür sage ich:
-Deine Existenz ist abgesichert.
-Das finde ich grundsätzlich gut zu sagen,
wir brauchen grundlegende
Menschenrechte. Da könnte ich jetzt schon wieder einen
Schritt vor machen, aber fast schon
wieder zurück, weil ich mich nämlich frage,
warum ein grundlegendes Menschenrecht
auf einen nominalen Geldbetrag? Warum sagt man
nicht, jeder soll ein Dach über dem Kopf
haben, Bildung, Zugang zu Kultur usw.?
-Warum ein nominaler Geldbetrag?
-Weil du es irgendwie bestimmen musst. Das
ist das Menschenbild des 20.
Jahrhunderts, wo eine Zentraleinheit wie z.B. der Staat
weiß, was ein gutes Leben
bedeutet. Und wir merken, es passt nicht mehr
auf die vielfältigen Lebensentwürfe.
Gib doch den Leuten das Geld und die können
selbst entscheiden. Vielleicht
will einer im Wald leben und hat gar keine
Mietkosten. Du kommst ja auch an eine Verwaltungsgrenze.
Du musst das ja alles
organisieren, wenn du sagst wie man
leben soll und dann den Leuten irgendwelche
Güter zuschanzt und wir merken
ja, das funktioniert nicht.
Ganz kurz zur Gerechtigkeitsfrage, da interessiert
mich natürlich eure Meinung.
Ist das bedingungslose Grundeinkommen
im Kern ungerecht? So wie es Ole gesagt hat?
Oder ist es im Gegenteil sogar
genau recht? Vielleicht sogar Menschenrecht,
wie es Mark gerade gesagt hat?
Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare und wir gehen
jetzt so ein bisschen
von der Gerechtigkeitsfrage hin
zur Sicherheitsfrage, zu Tonia. Du
hast ja mit dem bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen
eigentlich überhaupt gar nichts am Hut
gehabt. Aber was ist dann passiert?
Naja, nicht ganz gar nichts. Ich war
bis vor Corona zwar Sympathisant und fand
die Idee immer spannend, aber ja, dann
kam die Krise und die große Pressekonferenz
mit der Bazooka am 13. März
letztes Jahr. Ich habe auf Change am Anfang
der Corona-Krise eine Petition
gestartet für ein Kriesengrundeinkommen,
ein bedingungsloses, weil mir ganz
schnell klar war, dass sehr viele Menschen
in eine sehr ungewisse Situation
rutschen würden und viele, viele, viele Leute
einfach jetzt Sicherheit bräuchten.
Ja, ich weiß, es gibt diese Sicherheitsnetze,
aber es ist ein krasser
Bürokratieaufwand und ich weiß gerade
bei der Grundsicherung: Ganz
ganz, ganz, ganz ganz... ich glaube 5 %
der Selbstständigen, die eigentlich
gerade Anspruch hätten, beantragen sie,
weil die anderen alle Angst haben vor Repressalien.
Wenn ich dann irgendwo erst
mal stehe, kriege ich vielleicht
später keine Unternehmerkredite mehr,
was auch immer... Schamgrenze zu sagen,
Hey, ich habe 19 Jahre lang Arbeitsplätze
geschaffen oder für mich selbst
gesorgt. Also viele sind auch so, dass sie einfach
sagen, ich habe mich immer
selber an den Haaren aus dem Sumpf gezogen
und das schaffe ich jetzt irgendwie
auch, da verkaufe ich lieber vorher meine Möbel.
Und das heißt, du plädierst für ein Kriesengrundeinkommen
oder für ein immer
-geltendes?
-Also in diesem Fall und die Petition die
ich gestartet habe, damals
ging es um ein Kriesengrundeinkommen
während der Corona-Krise. Allerdings
hatte ich natürlich in dem Jahr so viel Kontakt
mit dem Thema Grundeinkommen, dass ich inzwischen
schon auch ganz klar einfach
die Vorteile sehe, die es für unsere Gesellschaft
hat. Mit einem Grundeinkommen
kannst du dann halt doch mal
irgendwann auch an dieser Stelle sagen: Okay,
Wir haben gerade eine Flaute,
aber ich weiß zumindest meine Miete
-und meine Krankenkasse sind gezahlt.
-Weniger Scham, weniger Bürokratie, mehr
-Sicherheit. Ulrike, überzeugt dich das?
-Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass es möglich
wäre, jetzt mitten in der Krise ein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen für alle
herzustellen. Denn das würde ja
beispielsweise bedeuten, dass Leute,
die eine Stelle haben, also im Extremfall
Beamte oder auch Leute, deren Jobs ganz
normal weiterlaufen, z.B. in der Bäckerei,
die sind ja auch im Vollbetrieb
oder in Lebensmittelläden oder im Online-Handel
oder die Industrie. Da geht
es ja schon wieder aufwärts, die haben
alle Jobs, die würden dann auch alle
das bedingungslose Grundeinkommen
bekommen. Und da würde ich dann einfach
-sagen: Da reicht das Geld nicht.
-Was ist denn die Vision dahinter? Warum
-wird die Gesellschaft dadurch besser?
-Wir müssen glaube ich mal eine Sache
klären, wenn es um die Finanzierung
geht. Ich hoffe, dass ich sagen kann, dass man
mich versteht. Das Grundeinkommen hat
ein großes Mysterium um sich und das ist
die Idee, das habe ich bei euch
gehört ist, dass alle Menschen 1200 Euro mehr
haben. So ein Grundeinkommen kann und wird
es niemals geben. Das wäre gedrucktes
Geld, wenn es vom Himmel fällt.
Inflation, sofort weg, gibt es nicht.
Grundeinkommen... Danke, da komme
ich auch direkt, ist doch schön. Es wird
umverteilt. Sie kriegen 1200 Euro im Monat
mehr. Das ist erst einmal schön, aber
das ist nur der Monatsanfang. Am Ende
zahlen Sie deutlich höhere Steuern
als heute. Das heißt, in der Mittelschicht
zahlen Sie wahrscheinlich im Mittel
auch ungefähr 1200 Euro pro Monat
Steuern mehr. Das heißt, unterm Strich haben
Sie nicht mehr Geld in der Tasche.
Das Schöne ist, das ist auch nicht schlimm.
Die haben aber eine Sicherheit.
Sie wissen, dass sie und ihre Kinder
bis zum Lebensende niemals in Armut
leben werden. Die Hoffnung ist, dass Menschen
dann klügere Entscheidungen fällen,
weil sie nicht mehr so tief fallen können.
Je nach Maß der Umverteilung, je nach Parteikonzept
ist das Grundeinkommen höher
oder niedriger und das bedeutet dann,
dass die Armen etwas mehr und die Reichen
weniger haben. Es ist eine große
Steuerreform, aber keine Steuerreform,
wo der Staat mir Geld wegnimmt und damit
Autobahnen wie jetzt in Berlin zu bauen,
sondern ein Umlageverfahren zwischen den Menschen.
Das heißt, es ist nicht mehr
Geld, deswegen gibt es keine
Inflation und deswegen ist es auch nicht schwer
zu finanzieren, denn die meisten
Menschen haben heute bereits 1200 Euro
oder deutlich mehr. Und Grundeinkommen
wächst quasi von unten in das existierende
-Einkommen hinein.
-Ja, aber das würde doch dann so laufen:
Dann hätte ich als vierköpfige Familie
schon mal 56 000 Euro Netto, wenn ich gar
nicht arbeite. So, dann denke ich mir
vielleicht Okay, jetzt will ich aber doch
ein bisschen arbeiten, macht ja Spaß.
Dann ist doch die Wahrscheinlichkeit groß,
dass ich sage Okay, ich mach aber nur eine Halbtagsstelle,
dann habe ich wahnsinnige
Steuern, aber insgesamt habe ich trotzdem
viel mehr als vorher und meine Steuern
reichen nicht um mich selbst zu finanzieren,
weil das wäre ja Quatsch
genau so viel zu arbeiten wie vorher,
wenn ich eigentlich auch ein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen machen kann.
Und stattdessen verfolge ich dann
meine Hobbies. Das ist auch zutiefst
menschlich und das will ich auch gar nicht
kritisieren, aber dann mache ich z.B.
den Kirchenchor so oder irgendetwas anderes.
So, und dann ist aber jetzt die Frage
ganz banal: Warum sollen die, die noch arbeiten
und Steuern zahlen und die nicht
gläubig sind, das Hobby von jemandem finanzieren,
-der jetzt den Kirchenchor leitet?
-Da gehe ich nach vorne, weil ich stimme
dir 100 % zu. Wenn es so ist, dass ein Grundeinkommen
die Menschen faul macht,
dann ist es nicht möglich,
nicht finanzierbar. Wir müssen ja Geld
umverteilen und dafür müssen
Menschen erwerbsarbeiten. Die Frage ist nur:
Arbeiten die Menschen nur deshalb, weil es ihnen
einen Vorteil gibt, weil sie dann
Geld haben? Oder arbeiten sie, weil es Sinn
stiftet, weil es das Leben sinnvoll
macht? Ich glaube, Menschen wollen
arbeiten und werden es auch viel besser
mit Grundeinkommen tun. Das erleben
wir auch bei den 700 Menschen, denen
wir Grundeinkommen ausgezahlt haben.
Die bilden sich weiter, die finden Jobs,
die sogar besser bezahlt werden. Da kommt
keiner, selbst Leute mit vier prekären
Jobs gleichzeitig, kommt keiner auf die Idee,
weniger zu tun. Und wir müssen
das rausfinden, lasst
es uns doch ausprobieren.
Lasst uns doch mal bitte ganz
kurz...Ulrike ist gerade mehrere Schritte
nach hinten gelaufen, obwohl ich gerade
dachte, ihr wärt euch einig geworden.
Aber jetzt bist du
trotzdem nach hinten gelaufen.
Ja natürlich, weil der Ansatz von Michael
ist ja: Wir erlauben den Menschen nicht
zu arbeiten, aber das kommt nicht so,
weil die arbeiten dann ja trotzdem. Aber
das ist Quatsch, weil alle
Systeme, die wir haben, alle Sozialsysteme,
Rechtssysteme und so weiter, sind
so ausgelegt, dass alle sie in Anspruch
nehmen können. Das ist der Witz.
So ist jedes Sozialsystem, Krankenkasse,
Unfallversicherung, alles, ist genau
so strukturiert. Wer berechtigt ist, darf
es in Anspruch nehmen. Nur das Grundeinkommen
wäre ein System, wo es so
laufen würde: Man hat ein Recht,
man darf es aber nicht in Anspruch nehmen.
Wenn das nämlich in alle alle in Anspruch
nehmen würden, würde es zusammenbrechen.
Sowas gibt es aber auf der Welt
nicht. Wenn es einen Rechtsanspruch gibt, muss
es möglich sein, dass alle
es in Anspruch nehmen.
Es geht ja gar nicht darum,
dass Sozialbudget umzuverteilen,
sondern es geht eigentlich
eher ums Volkseinkommen. Also
das Bruttoinlandsprodukt muss
umverteilt werden, darum geht es. Und das wird
passieren müssen. Das wird es mit sich
bringen. Was aber nicht bedeutet,
dass es...Also diese Frage, ist
es finanzierbar? Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Es ist erwiesen in vielen Studien,
dass die Höhe von Transferleistungen,
dass die Auszahlung sogar von einem
bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen über viele
Jahre über tausende von Menschen
keinen relevanten Effekt hat auf die Frage,
ob ich arbeiten gehe oder nicht. Der Mensch
ist ein soziales Wesen, er möchte
tätig sein. Menschen haben
Depressionen, weil sie keine Arbeit haben, sie wollen
-etwas beitragen.
-Karsten, seid ihr da drüben ein bisschen
zu verbissen in Details und Umsetzbarkeit?
Und seht nicht das große Ganze,
die Vision, die er gerade
gezeichnet hat? Karsten?
-Achso, hast du mich gerade gefragt?
-Ja, du bist doch Karsten.
Ja, ja, ja, ich dachte,
du hast Ole angeguckt.
Nee, nee, ich hab so zu gelb geschaut.
Also ich habe gerade den Eindruck, dass du
mehr oder weniger monierst... dass hier
nicht einmal quasi "out of the box"...
Ja, träumt doch mal, wir wollen doch
eine andere Welt. Das geht doch so nicht weiter
wie heute. Jetzt
probieren wir mal was aus.
Ich bin ja gerne dabei, so etwas zu träumen.
Aber ich kann ja nichts
gegen meine Ängste oder gegen meine Bedenken
machen, nur weil du dich
-hinstellt und sagst: "Das wird schon."
-Nein, das stimmt nicht. Es ist auf Fakten
basierend, was ich euch erzähle. Nur wir müssen
noch mehr Forschung schaffen.
Es gibt aber auch schon eine Menge
und wir müssen nicht so tun, als würden
die Menschen sofort aufhören zu arbeiten.
Es ist nicht zu belegen.
Das sag ich ja überhaupt nicht.
Nur dann...Also du stimmst mir doch
grundsätzlich zu, dass wenn die Menschen
aufhören würden zu arbeiten. Ich sage
jetzt nicht alle hören auf zu arbeiten,
sondern auch nur 10 %, 20 % der Arbeit
wird nicht mehr getan, dann steht
dem nominalen Bruttoinlandsprodukt ein real
-gesenktes BIP entgegen.
-Das stimmt, ja.
Das bedeutet also, die Menschen haben
real weniger. Das ist okay. Wir können gerne
meinetwegen sagen, wir arbeiten
weniger, haben dafür weniger, machen schöne Sachen,
machen den Kirchenchor. Finde ich prima.
Muss man aber so kommunizieren
und das wird nicht getan. Stattdessen
wird gesagt: Heute reichen 1200 Euro aus,
um sich ein prima Leben leisten zu können,
das versprochene 1200 Euro Grundeinkommen,
obwohl wir wissen, da sind wir ja
zusammengekommen eben, dass diese 1200
Euro vielleicht nicht mehr reichen
nach Einführung des Grundeinkommens. Und dann
kommen wir einfach nur in eine Grundeinkommensinflationsspirale.
Das stimmt. Ich gehe
jetzt ganz nach vorne.
Du sollst immer nur bei der Gegenseite
nach vorne gehen.
-Achso.
-Ach, laufe doch hin, wo du willst.
Das gilt ja heute schon. Also
was wissen wir über die Zukunft?
Also ich habe da mal eine Frage.
Würde irgendwer von uns sechs...Was würde
es für uns einzelne persönlich
verändern, wenn wir jetzt das Grundeinkommen kriegen
-würden?
-Wie schon gesagt: Für mich gar nichts. Ja,
-gut, für dich auch nicht.
-Spannenderweise sagt wirklich fast jeder,
mit dem man im Gespräch drauf kommt,
fast jeder sagt: Also ich würde nichts ändern,
ich würde genauso
weiterarbeiten wie bisher.
Aber kann das daran liegen, dass man
immer auch mit verhältnismäßig privilegierten
Leuten redet? Ich bin Podcaster, ich bin
Buchautor. Ja, was ich mache, macht mir
Spaß. Ich bin erfüllt, es bringt auch ne
Menge soziale Anerkennung, trifft nicht
für alle zu. Was ist mit denen,
auf die das nicht zutrifft?
Da steckt aus meiner Sicht ein versteckter
Chauvinismus dahinter, der nämlich sagt,
arme Menschen sind
ein bisschen dumm und faul.
Nein, das habe ich doch überhaupt
nicht gesagt. Es gibt Berufe die finanziell
-sehr schlecht bezahlt sind.
-Ich habe hunderten von Menschen
Grundeinkommen ausgezahlt mit meinem
Verein über die letzten Jahre. Ich habe
mit der Lupe danach gesucht, nach der einen
Person, die Alkohol kauft und faul
wird und völlig
verloddert. Das Gegenteil ist passiert.
-Aber das erzählt doch auch keiner von uns.
-Ne das sagt doch keiner. Wir sagen: Die
sozialversicherungspflichtige
Beschäftigung geht zurück und stattdessen
machen die Leute Kirchenchor. Die sind
nicht faul. Der Punkt ist nur sie machen
nicht die Arbeit, jedenfalls
nicht in dem Ausmaß wie bisher, auf denen
das Steuersystem
basiert. Das ist unsere Behauptung.
-Das ist Spekulation.
-Und das wird auch für Leute gelten, die
Lehrer sind, die Journalisten
sind und so weiter.
Aber was heißt Spekulation? Lasst mal
kurz Mark wieder reinholen. Entschuldigung.
Mark meldet sich schon die ganze
Zeit. Entschuldigung, bevor wir uns verbeißen.
Ich glaube, dass wir es einfach
noch nicht wissen. Ich glaube,
dass wir es wahrscheinlich nie
wissen werden, wenn wir es nicht ausprobieren?
Ich glaube, das ist aber gleichzeitig
auch der Punkt, dass ich sage: Nicht nur Geld
hat einen Wert für unsere Gesellschaft,
sondern es gibt so viele Aspekte
von Zusammenleben. Es gibt so viele
Aspekte auch von Arbeit, von Betätigung,
die wichtig sind für unsere Gesellschaft,
die ich jetzt nicht außer Acht lassen
würde. Und gleichzeitig denke
ich trotzdem, dass es vielleicht sogar
sein könnte, dass wir danach mehr
Erwerbsarbeit haben, mehr Erwerbstätigkeit
-haben als heute. Das wissen wir nicht.
-Ich glaube, dass der Dissens, der hier
manchmal im Raum steht, dass der gar
nicht so groß da ist. Deshalb muss
ich auch das mit dem Sozialchauvinismus
ganz entschieden von mir weisen,
weil ich auch nicht möchte, dass Leute
schlecht bezahlte Jobs machen müssen.
Ich möchte auch nicht, dass Menschen
durch Hartz-IV Sanktionen da reingezwängt
werden. Da bin ich komplett eurer
Meinung. Nur ich halte das Grundeinkommen weiterhin
trotzdem für den falschen
Weg, muss ich leider sagen.
Lasst uns doch an dieser Stelle mal
eine Runde der Kompromisse machen zum Ende.
Ihr wisst ja, mir geht es zumindest
darum, auch bei klarem Dissens irgendwie
zu gucken: Wo gibt's einen Konsens?
Wir versuchen das mal rauszufinden. Ihr seid
gleich selbst innerhalb eurer
Gruppen aufgefordert, einen Kompromissvorschlag
zu machen, wo ihr sagt, vielleicht
gehen die anderen da einen Schritt auf mich zu.
Ich biete selber auch einen
Vorschlag an, ich glaube, den auch schon mehr
oder weniger herausgehört zu haben.
Also der Vorschlag lautet: Wenigstens
die Menschen, die heute Hartz IV
empfangen, sollten in ein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen überführt
werden. Unbürokratisch, ohne Stigmata...
Aber das wäre ja ein bedingtes
Grundeinkommen.
Genau, also innerhalb dieser Kaste
wäre es quasi ein bedingungsloses, aber quasi
ein bedingtes Grundeinkommen für die Menschen,
die heutzutage Hartz IV
empfangen. Wäre das ein Kompromissvorschlag,
wo ihr sagt: Da gehe
-ich einen Schritt vor oder nicht?
-Also ich würde einen halben vorgehen.
Also es gibt eine leichte Bewegung in die Richtung,
aber Ulrike bleibt noch stehen.
Ja, aber zum Beispiel fände ich es schon
richtig, dass weiterhin versucht wird,
-Leute in Arbeit zu vermitteln.
-Also das Prinzip des Forderns und Förderns
-würde dann aufgehoben werden.
-Also ich glaube nicht, dass ich das
-unterstützen würde.
-Okay, jetzt würde ich euch bitten: Geht
kurz in euch. Am besten, ihr könnt
euch gerne zusammenstellen. Merkt euch
ungefähr eure Position, bitte. Macht
es ganz kurz, jetzt nicht ewig lang denken
und rumformulieren. Gibt es irgendeinen
Punkt, wo ihr sagt: Damit kriegen
wir die anderen ein bisschen näher zu uns?
Während meine Gäste noch am diskutieren
sind: Wenn ihr auch vielleicht
einen Vorschlag habt, wie können hier beide
Seiten näher zusammenkommen, dann
schreibt es mir gerne in die Kommentare. Bin
sehr gespannt. Ist ja ein wichtiges
Thema, was uns alle angeht und offenbar gibt
es ja auch den Bedarf nach Kompromissen.
Ich bin gespannt. So, Damen und Herren,
wir kommen langsam zum Schluss,
bitte. Ihr dürft euren ersten Vorschlag machen.
Naja, wir hatten hier
so eine Art Gruppensprecher.
-Ole ist der Gruppensprecher?
-Naja, ich hatte den Eindruck, dass wir
auch innerhalb der Gruppe einen
kleinen Dissenz hatten, weil Ulrike
gegen die Aufhebung der Sanktionen
ist, ich würde gerne Hartz IV Sanktionen
aufheben, von daher würden wir vielleicht
einen moderateren Vorschlag machen,
wo wir alle hinter stehen: Das wäre
eine Erhöhung von Hartz IV, dass das nicht mehr
künstlich klein gerechnet wird
so wie es jetzt gerade stattfindet.
Insbesondere die erniedrigenden
Praktiken von Jobcentern, was Ulrike meinte, da wird
noch im Badezimmer geguckt, wie viele
Zahnbürsten da sind so ein bisschen
übertrieben gesprochen. All
das muss aufhören würden wir sagen.
-Genau.
-Also Hartz IV radikal verbessern, aber die
-Sanktionen nicht gänzlich abschaffen.
-Naja, Sanktionen klingt ja so, so
drakonisch. Ich meine, es muss
schon so sein, dass die Leute tatsächlich
arbeitslos sind. Und das muss
auch kontrolliert werden. Also nicht
in dem Sinne, dass jeder, der sagt
"ich will Hartz 4" zum Jobcenter gehen kann.
-Die Bedingung wäre ein Bedarf.
-Ja genau.
Aber der Bedarf, kann der nicht auch sein,
ich bin alleinerziehend und arbeite
-deswegen nur 30 Stunden und brauche...
-Ja, das finde ich völlig okay.
Genau, weil das ist ja noch nicht Hartz
IV im Moment, aber trotzdem an einem Minimum
Existenz... Deswegen finde ich die Begrenzung
auf Hartz IV da ein bisschen
-schwierig.
-Ja, man kann natürlich sagen
-Grundsicherung.
-Ich glaube, du musst die Grenze woanders
-einziehen.
-Ja, Hartz IV müsste weiter oben sein, das
-ist das, was wir vorschlagen.
-Und wer entscheidet den Punkt, weswegen
derjenige den Bedarf hat, angemessen
ist oder nicht? Es könnte z.B. sein: Ich will
nochmal eine Umschulung machen in einem
bestimmten Alter, will nochmal
-eine Ausbildung machen.
-Aus meiner Sicht ist es so, dass das dann
tatsächlich trotzdem das Jobcenter
entscheiden muss, weil ich glaube,
anders als ihr, ganz
pragmatisch gesprochen: Es gibt nicht
die gesellschaftliche Bereitschaft,
Leute bedingungslos zu finanzieren. Also
die Gesellschaft ist nur bereit,
dieses Geld aufzubringen, also in Form
einer bedingten Grundsicherung,
die sehr viel besser ausgestattet ist,
wenn sie das Gefühl haben, okay, da wird
auch geguckt, wer kriegt das denn jetzt
-und warum?
-Na gut, das könnte ja sein, dass sich das
auch ändert. Die gesellschaftliche
Bereitschaft könnte ja nach den 200
Pilotprojekten auch ganz
woanders sein theoretisch.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber ich rede ja jetzt
von der Gegenwart, und nicht von der Zukunft.
Okay, habt ihr euch
irgendwie bewegt? Ihr seid so... ja?
Ich würde mal versuchen, für uns
zu sprechen, dass wir uns sehr wünschen,
dass die aktuelle soziale
Sicherung verbessert wird, dass Menschen
aus der akuten Armut geholt
werden, weil das ist ein riesen Problem.
Corona verschärft es und macht es noch
sichtbar. Das ist ein absolut notwendiger
Schritt, zu dem wir alle stehen.
Ihr könntet also auch dazu einen Schritt
vorwärts gehen. Trotzdem müssen wir leider
sagen, dass wir beim Thema Bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen nicht bereit sind,
Abstriche zu machen. Es ist eine radikal
einfache Idee, eine Idee, die nicht
versucht, ein kaputtes System irgendwie
back zu fixen und ein bisschen halbwegs
Armut zu verdecken, indem man nachträglich
in Not geratene Menschen, die es immer
wieder geben wird in diesem System,
irgendwie über die Runden zu bringen.
Sondern wir wollen ein System,
in dem von vornherein niemand in die Not
gerät, in denen Menschen nicht misstraut
wird, in denen sie nicht kontrolliert
werden von einem Staat, der sagt, wann man
Leistungen kriegt und wann nicht.
Sondern wir wollen eine Welt, in der Menschen
vertraut wird, weil wir glauben, dass sie dann
über sich hinauswachsen und eine neue
Welt schaffen. Deshalb für euch
heute leider kein Kompromissangebot.
-Darf ich noch einen letzten machen?
-Ich wollte noch eine Frage stellen.
-Ja, hast du noch eine?
-Ja, ich habe noch eine fixe Idee. Was ist
denn, wenn man das Grundeinkommen
nicht gleich von Beginn der Geburt macht,
-sondern zum späteren Zeitpunkt?
-Gibt's Konzepte zu, die meisten sagen ab
-18.
-Ich weiß nicht, was für Konzepte es gibt,
aber dass du sagst, du fängst mit 30,
40 an. Also ich sag mal, ich bin jetzt Mitte
Vierzig. Angenommen, ich könnte mich
nicht selbst verwirklichen, hätte jetzt aber
Bock, nochmal eine Sprache zu lernen
oder von mir aus auch nur zu reisen
oder nochmal ein neues Business
aufzuziehen oder sowas. Also das wäre
für mich so eine Sache. Meine Befürchtung
war ja auch, dass den Schulabgängern,
Studienabgängern erst einmal
das Arbeitsleben gezeigt werden muss,
integriert werden müssen, aber haben
eine Perspektive, dass sie irgendwann mal
-was anderes machen können.
-Das Charmante an dieser Idee ist, dass es
aufhört, Menschen in Gruppen zu unterteilen.
Sonst brauchst du immer
jemand, der entscheidet, welche
Lobbygruppe setzt sich quasi durch?
Dann haben z.B. die Kinder
und die Erwerbslosen und die Armen
und die Ausländer haben dann
alle keine Lobbygruppe und kriegen dann
komischerweise wieder nichts.
Ein Grundeinkommen sagt: Schluss
mit dem Quatsch,
alle kriegen genug. Punkt.
So, ich mache noch einen
allerletzten Kompromissvorschlag, nur damit das mal
auf dem Tisch liegt. Ein bedingungsloses
nicht Einkommen,
sondern eine bedingungslose
Finanzspritze nenne ich es mal. Zum Beispiel zum 18.
Lebensjahr bekommt jeder vom Staat
30 000 Euro überwiesen. Das ist um einiges
günstiger als ein BGE. 30 000 Euro,
du kannst damit machen, was du willst,
kannst du in ein Haus investieren,
kannst reisen gehen, kannst keine Ahnung
was machen. Du springst gleich nach vorne,
manche gehen gleich nach hinten. Was sagt
ihr? Nur ganz kurz. Kurze
Einschätzung, keine langen Reden. Warum bist du
-nach vorne gegangen?
-Weil ich glaube, dass man ein wirkliches
Sicherheitsgefühl vor allem durch
Vermögen und nicht so sehr durch Einkommen kriegt.
Und ich glaube, dass das für ganz
viel mehr Chancengleichheit sorgen würde.
Wobei ich sagen würde, dass es ungerecht
ist. Das ist jetzt wirklich mal
Gießkannenprinzip. Jeder kriegt
gleich viel zum 18. Geburtstag und das halte
-ich persönlich einfach für ungerecht.
-Das stimmt. Da gehe ich einen
Tippel-Schritt zurück, weil das ist
natürlich auch ein Punkt, ja.
Gut, jetzt sind aber alle Vorschläge
mal auf dem Tisch gewesen, darum geht's ja
-auch.
-Wir haben es schon oft miteinander
probiert, wir sind uns halt nicht einig
geworden. Aber ich glaube, wenn ich das so
interpretieren darf, Ulrike wünscht
sich im Alten mehr und ich wünsche mir
etwas komplett Neues. Und da kommt
man schon von jeher nicht so gut zusammen.
Aber deswegen macht es umso mehr
Spaß, sich da immer wieder dran auszutauschen.
Ich glaube, was wichtig ist, wir sind
uns einig im Ziel. Also wir wollen ja beide,
dass kein Mensch in Armut lebt, wir wollen
beide, dass die Menschen glücklich sind,
wir wollen, dass kein Druck ausgeübt
wird. Aber ich glaube, der Unterschied ist
-im Weg.
-Also ich nehme für mich mit, dass ich eure
Seite vielleicht besser
verstehe. Aber Fragen sind geblieben.
Klar, bei mir bleiben auch Fragen.
Also ich muss ja schon zugeben, mit den großen
Wirtschaftszahlen, das überlasse
ich auch immer gerne anderen.
-Den Profis, ne?
-Genau, den ganzen anderen
Grundeinkommens-Profis. Und ich glaube
halt einfach trotzallem: Man muss
-es einfach ausprobieren.
-Ich fand diese Diskussion super spannend.
Ich hatte auch das Gefühl, dass wir uns
in vielen Punkten irgendwie ganz gut ergänzen
und auch nicht so weit auseinander
sind. Ich weiß nicht, wie du es siehst, Ole?
Das sehe ich eigentlich ganz genauso.
Ich möchte auch nicht, dass Leute schlecht
bezahlte Jobs annehmen, ich möchte
auch, dass man ein Dach über dem Kopf hat
und abgesichert ist. Aber das Instrument
halte ich leider weiterhin für falsch.
Vielleicht geht der Hebel ja
irgendwann auf die andere Seite. Da hab ich immer
noch Hoffnung auch nach unserer
heutigen Diskussion hat sich gezeigt: Da gibt's
schon Potenzial, dass wir uns
da immer weiter annähern.
Natürlich ist es am Ende des Tages
spannend. Also hier war viel Bewegung
auf dem Spielfeld. Vielen Dank dafür.
Finde ich super, dass ihr auch aufeinander
zugeht und manchmal dann auch wieder
einen Schritt zurück geht. Wie geht es euch?
Wo steht ihr? Seid ihr mehr Team
gelb oder Team grün? Für bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen oder dagegen?
Oder vielleicht für einen
dieser Kompromissvorschläge? Ich habe
das Gefühl, die mindestens Reform von Hartz IV
steht auf jeden Fall ganz oben auf allen
Prioritätenlisten, zumindest als erster
Schritt. Vielen, vielen Dank fürs
Mitmachen. 13 FRAGEN war das. Danke. Ja,
natürlich hat weder Team grün noch
Team gelb restlos überzeugt oder umgekehrt.
Aber was ich so spannend fand an dieser Diskussion,
dass sich sowas rausgestellt
hat, dann doch so eine Gemeinsamkeit,
so ein Konsens darüber, dass man
Sozialsysteme in Deutschland ganz
offenbar besser aufstellen muss. Und das ist ja
schon mal was. Welche Argumente
haben euch überzeugt? Schreibt es gerne
in die Kommentare und wenn ihr mehr
Lust auf 13 FRAGEN habt, hier könnt ihr unseren
Kanal abonnieren, hier oben findet ihr ein weiteres
Video von 13 FRAGEN. Und hier
gibt es noch ein Video zum Thema.